this exercise is from chapter 12 of the
COTS treacle and Townsend chemistry and
chemical reactivity book and I'm doing
it with their permission so they tell us
you place two litres of water in an open
container in your dormitory room the
room has a volume of 4.25 times 10 to
the 4th litres you seal the room and
wait for the water to evaporate will all
of the water evaporate at 25 degrees
Celsius and then they tell us at 25
degrees Celsius the density of water is
0.997
grams per milliliter and it's vapor
pressure it's vapor pressure is
twenty-three point 8 millimeters of
mercury and this is actually the key
clue to tell you how to solve this
problem and just as a bit of review
let's just think about what vapor
pressure is let's think about what vapor
pressure is let's say it's some
temperature and in this case we're
dealing at 25 degrees Celsius I have a
bunch of water and let me do that in a
water color I have a bunch of water
molecules sitting here in a container
sitting here in a container at 25
degrees Celsius they're all bouncing
around in every which way and in every
which way and every now and then one of
them is going to have enough kinetic
energy to kind of escape the hydrogen
bonds and all the things that keep
liquid water and slick would stayed in
the little scape it'll go off in that
direction and then another one will and
this will just keep happening the water
will naturally vaporize in a room but at
some point enough of these molecules
have vaporized enough of these molecules
have vaporized over here that they're
also bumping back into the water and
maybe some of them can be captured back
into the liquid state now the point the
pressure at which this happens is the
vapor pressure as you can imagine is
more and more of these as more and more
of these water molecules vaporize and go
into the gaseous state more and more
will also create pressure downward
pressure more and more will also be
colliding with the surface of the water
and the pressure at which the liquid and
the vapor State are in equilibrium is
the vapor pressure and they telling us
right now
it is twenty three point eight
millimeters of mercury now what we need
to do is figure out to figure out this
problem and say okay how many if we
could figure out how many molecules need
to evaporate how many molecules of water
need to evaporate to give us this vapor
pressure we can then use the density of
water to figure out how many liters of
water that is so how do we figure out
how many how many molecules let me write
this down how many how much how many
molecules how many molecules of water
need to evaporate to evaporate to give
us the vapor pressure to give us the
vapor pressure to give us the vapor
pressure of 23.8 millimeters of mercury
so what I guess law or formula I don't
never like to just memorize formulas but
we've given this formula in the past and
it's probably one of the top most useful
formulas in chemistry or really I all of
science what formula or law deals with
pressure they give us they give us the
volume of the room because that's where
the pressure will be inside of so we
have pressure the equilibrium vapor
pressure we have a volume of a room
right over here we know the temperature
of the room right over there and we are
trying to figure out the number of
molecules that need to evaporate for us
to get that pressure in that volume at
that temperature so what what deals with
pressure volume number of molecules
let's say in moles so our lowercase n
number of molecules and temperature well
we've seen this many many times it's the
ideal gas law pressure times volume is
equal to the number of moles of our
ideal gas in this case we're going to
we're going to use water as our ideal
gas or vapor as our ideal
x times the universal gas constant times
temperature and this should never seem
like some bizarre formula to you because
it really really makes sense if your
pressure goes up then that means that
either the number of molecules have gone
up and we're assuming volume is constant
that means either the number of
molecules have gone up which makes sense
more things bouncing on to the side of
the container or your temperature has
gone up the same number of things but
they're bumping with higher kinetic
energy or if you're but if your pressure
stays the same and your volume goes up
then that also means that your number of
molecules went up or your temperature
went up because you now have a bigger
container in order to exert the same
pressure you need more either more
molecules or more kinetic energy for the
molecules you have and you could keep
playing around with this but I just want
to make it clear this isn't some
mysterious formula the first time I was
exposed to this I kind of did view it as
some type of mysterious formula but it's
just relating pressure volume number of
molecules and temperature and then this
is just the ideal gas or sorry the
universal gas constant so let's just get
everything into the right units here and
then what we're trying to solve for we
want to figure out the number of
molecules of water so we want to solve
we want to solve for n and if we know
the number of moles of water we can
figure out the number of grams of water
and then given the density of water we
can figure out the number of milliliters
of water we are dealing with so let's
just rewrite the ideal gas law by
dividing both sides by the universal gas
constant and temperature so that you get
n is equal to pressure times volume over
the universal gas constant times
temperature now the hardest thing about
this is just making sure you have your
unit's right and you're using their
right ideal gas constant for the right
units and we'll do that right here so
what I want to do because the ideal the
ideal gas cottle gas constant I have is
in terms of atmospheres we need to
figure out this vapor pressure this
equilibrium pressure between vapor and
liquid we need to write this down in
terms of atmospheres so let me write
this down so the vapor pressure the
vapor
sure the vapor pressure is equal to 23
point 8 millimeters millimeters of
mercury and you can look it up at a
table if you don't have this if you just
don't have this in your brain one
atmosphere one atmosphere is equivalent
to 760 760 millimeters of mercury so if
we wanted to write the vapor pressure as
atmospheres let me get my calculator out
the calculator out put it right over
there so it's going to be twenty three
point eight twenty three point eight
times one over 760 or just divided by
760 and we have three significant digits
so it looks like 0.03 one three so this
is equal to 0.03 one three atmospheres
that is our vapor pressure so let's just
deal with this right here so the number
of molecules of water then that are
going to be in the air and the gaseous
state in the vapor State or is going to
be equal to our vapor pressure that's
our equilibrium pressure above if more
while more water molecules evaporate
after that point then we're going to
have a higher pressure which will
actually make them favor more of them
going into the liquid state so we'll go
kind of past the equilibrium which is
not likely or another way to think about
more water molecules are not going to
evaporate at a faster rate than they are
going to condense beyond that pressure
anyway the pressure here is zero point
zero three one three atmospheres the
volume here they told us right over here
is four point so that's the volume four
point two five four point two five times
ten to the fourth times 10 to the fourth
liters and then we want to divide that
by you want to make sure that your
universal gas constant has the right
units I just looked mine up on Wikipedia
zero point zero eight see everything has
three significant digits so I'll just
let me just a lot more significant
digits and we'll just round at the end
zero point zero
eight to zero five seven five seven and
the unit's here are liters atmospheres
liters atmospheres per mole per mole per
mole Kelvin and this makes sense this
leader will cancel out with that leader
that atmospheres cancel out with that
atmospheres I'm about to multiply it by
temperature right here in Kelvin will
cancel out there and then I don't have a
1 over moles in the denominator a 1 over
moles in the denominator will just be a
moles because you're going to invert it
again so that gives us our answer in
moles and so finally our temperature and
you got to remember you got to do it in
Kelvin so 25 degrees Celsius let me
write it over here 25 degrees Celsius is
equal to you just add 273 to it so this
is equal to 200 and 298 298 Kelvin so
times 298 Kelvin and now we just have to
calculate this so let's do that so we
have so let me clear this out so we have
use my my keyboard so point 0 3 1 3
atmospheres times 4 4.25 4.25 times 10
to the fourth that's just that II just
means times 10 to the fourth that's the
way that it works on this calculator and
then divided by point zero eight two
zero five seven divided by so I could
let you actually let me make it just to
make it clear let me show you that I'm
dividing by this whole thing so let me
insert let me insert some parentheses
right here some parentheses and so in
the denominator we also are multiplying
by 298 and let me close the parentheses
let me close the parentheses and then we
get 50 4.4 we only have three
significant digits so this is equal to
this is equal to
54.4 moles and we could see this leaders
cancels out with that leaders Kelvin
cancels out with Kelvin atmospheres with
atmospheres you have a one over mole in
the denominator so then you just des
agree to one over one over moles is just
going to be moles now this is going to
be fifty four point four moles of water
vapor in the room to have our vapor
pressure if our if more evaporates then
more will condense we will be beyond our
equilibrium so we won't ever have more
than this amount evaporate in that room
so let's figure out how much liquid
water that actually is so fifty four let
me do it over here so fifty four fifty
four point four moles let me write it
down moles of h2o that's going to be in
this vapor form it's going to evaporate
but let's figure out how many grams that
is so what is the what is the molar mass
of water
well it's roughly eighteen I actually
figure it out exactly it's actually
eighteen point zero one if you if you
actually use the exact numbers on on the
periodic table at least the one that I
used so we could say we could say that
there's eighteen point zero one grams of
h2o for every one mole of h2o and
obviously you can just look up the
atomic weights of hydrogen which is a
little bit over one and the atomic
weight of oxygen which is a little bit
below 16 so you have two of these so two
plus sixteen gives you pretty close to
eighteen so this this right here will
tell you the grams of water that can
evaporate to get us to that equilibrium
pressure so let's get the calculator out
so we have the fifty-four point four
fifty four point four times eighteen
point zero one is equal to nine hundred
and seventy well we only have three
significant digits so nine hundred if
you round this point seven it becomes
nine hundred and eighty so this is 980
grams of h2o
needs to evaporate for us to get to our
equilibrium pressure to our vapor
so let's figure out how many milliliters
of water this is so they tell us the
debt the density of water right here
0.997 limit is in darker darker color
0.997
grams per milliliter or another way you
could view this is for every one
milliliter for every one milliliter you
have 0.997 grams of water of water at 25
degrees Celsius so for every milliliter
this is grams per milliliter we want
milliliters per gram because we want
this and this to cancel out so we're
essentially just going to divide 980 by
0.997 so what is that get the calculator
out so we have 980 not cover up our work
divided by 0.997 is equal to 980 we'll
just around this 983 so this is equal to
this is equal to 983 this and this
cancelled out or that and that cancelled
out so 980 3 milliliters of h2o so we've
figured out using the ideal gas law that
900 at 25 degrees celsius which was 298
kelvin that nine hundred and
eighty-three milliliters of h2o will
evaporate to get us to our equilibrium
vapor pressure if any nothing more will
evaporate because beyond that if we have
more higher pressure than that then
you'll actually have you'll also have
more vapor going to the liquid state
because you'll have more stuff more
stuff bouncing here so this is the this
is if this much if this much volume of
water evaporates we'll have the state
where just as much as evaporating as
just as much as condensing so you will
never have a high you will never get to
a higher pressure than that at that
temperature so going back to the
question we figured out that 980 3
milliliters of water will evaporate the
question was is that we place two liters
of water in an open container so we just
figured out that only 980 3 milliliters
of that so that's a little bit less than
a liter
so this is a little bit less so this is
a little bit less than 1,000 milliliters
and this is one liter so a little bit
less a little bit less than half of this
will evaporate for us to get to our
vapor pressure so to answer our question
will all of the water evaporate at 25
degrees Celsius no if the water swimming
the room is sealed well no all of it
will not only a little bit less than
half of it will